last of all how can I find out what life
is like as a student at Oxford or
Cambridge this is arguably the most
important question of all I mean how can
you be expected to apply to university
and not know what the life hair is like
fortunately though there are lots of
great resources available online to
answer this question firstly for both
universities each College has its own
website and associated social media
accounts as do some departments these
give an excellent flavor of what student
life is like however recently there has
been a movement to create more
student-led initiatives which give an
honest boots-on-the-ground perspective
some of these projects are under a semi
official guide so for example the some
Peter's College YouTube channel is under
the college's name but is run by
students while other projects are
completely run and curated by students
both the official and unofficial
projects have their own advantages and I
highly recommend that you check out both
for a truly rounded picture of what life
Oxbridge is like and for each University
there are a few projects that deserve
special mention for Cambridge there's
fantastic YouTube channel run by Jake
right a recent Computer Sciences
graduate from Queens College who created
vlogs for his entire degree taking you
with him free lectures problem sheets
bops and many many trips to Wetherspoons
it's a fantastic and well produced
account of life as a Cambridge student I
highly recommend it in addition to this
project on Twitter there is also the
hashtag can tweet project where users at
Cambridge will use the hashtag Cam tweet
in tweets about their daily lives so the
search feed for the hashtag becomes an
interesting cross section across the
whole university going across courses
colleges and years if you have Twitter
than you can follow individual accounts
and those accounts are always very happy
to answer applicants questions in Oxford
there is the sister project hashtag ox
tweet which was the brainchild of
youtuber Jamie miles and instantly
inspired the Cambridge project jamie has
his own fu channel where he's made
several videos talking you through the
admissions process and has also made
several videos about his college and his
degree jamie is also the founder along
with it was truly of the ox blog project
Oxford started in my final year where I
started making weekly videos about my
student life and in the second term I
was joined by Jamie and after I
graduated we both set up the ox blog
channel where a team of five students
from across the university make vlogs
about their lives and they cover
different colleges subjects and year
projects now in its third year and is
still going strong making videos about
every aspect of student life from worked
socializing and everything in between
those are all the questions I hope that
this video has been useful to you and
alleviated at least some of your fears
but before I go I want to emphasize
something I said earlier your background
does not determine how likely it is that
you're going to get into Oxford or
Cambridge the only thing that they care
about is your academic ability and
potential and don't let anybody tell you
otherwise because it's simply not true
people believe in awful lot of myths and
misconceptions about Oxford but this is
the most persistent and it's by far the
most damaging don't be put up lying
because you think that you're not going
to get in because of who you were born
to or where you were born it really
doesn't matter check out all the
websites in the description for more
information and if you can't find the
answer to your question there then
remember that you can contact with
colleges and departments directly about
access issues and if you have a question
to me then you can also leave that down
in the comments below and if I can I'll
try and reply with an answer thanks for
watching if you found this useful then
please consider giving it a like and
share it with other people who are
interested in applying to Oxford or
Cambridge